there's a line here we're all dinair
right Aaron whatever it doesn't matter
but all yeah Aaron right Aaron Aaron
right Aaron I thought we established
that you're not gonna talk over me
[Laughter]
punching was bad hey reject nation no
hey be professional case I mean no this
is a hangout show I'm Craig Kasey Spivey
read that name correctly so you don't
get it confused with someone who we
alienate from the industry now oh you
think see my name and then you think of
a famous person I think that's a good
okay yeah it's a good way it's a good
thing we talk about the same thing okay
well Casey I've heard of a franchise
called Star Wars it's like indie film
it's yeah yeah a high concept low-budget
territory they just released the TV spot
for a spin-off to a movie we all want to
see a solo a Star Wars story as TV spots
called risk it stars white people which
you can relate to in a galaxy far far
away I know right whoa
wait a long time for a shot like this
what are you doing here you dick we need
a ship isn't for everyone
genetically type of plant
[Music]
[Music]
there's a lesson to be learned here
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
which was entirely sure where you were
at with that of that response there I
want to see Ward Donald Glover I know it
Dom Glover looks like he's gonna be the
highlight of it he should be it should
be the Lando movie it actually makes the
most sense wouldn't it you weirdly this
TV spot kind of gave me some insight
into where Hans art could actually be
enlighten me
I shall enlighten you Casey the first
Star Wars movie pawn is like he hasn't
wants nothing to do with anything you
know he's just his own rogue character
what's this whole thing with his
backstory that we're seeing in these
trailers of I want to be the greatest
pilot in the world and like fight the
rebellion like all these things like
that's not where Han started like when
he's older it seems like to me just from
this trailer that Han is someone who
starts off as this trustworthy dude a
guy who was really optimistic and
hopeful and who's probably gonna harken
to like some cynical dude by the end of
this movie because you know Woody
Harrelson's characters up in his face
saying you can't trust anyone and yada
yada yada I imagined that this is
probably gonna end in a way where it's
not so good for Han by the end of it all
maybe he gets his heart broken yeah
exactly
because the way the tribesmen market is
like this is like optimistic young Han
so I imagine that yeah you're right he's
probably getting his heart broken all
dinero right when he when he says I've
been waiting a long time for this wait a
long time for a shot like this kind of
feels a little self-aware because this
guy's probably waited a long time for
some big break like this and he's been
getting nothing but backlash for the
entire time cuz there was that drama
that happened with the studio and the
Lord and Chris Miller yes yes yeah so
there was drama there yeah everyone's
been like oh what happened but I think
that it was between Alden and the
directors I heard he went to the studio
yeah I'm talked mad [ __ ] about a
director's yeah oh they're making me do
all this making me improvise yeah yeah
it's comedy it's comedy comedy was like
no no man we're gonna stand by you and
these guys are fired I'm really curious
to see how this turns out I feel like
you want him to do a bad job I wanted to
be funny and I don't think I'm gonna get
no I'm kind of there with you like if
any of one of these Star Wars movie
should have a good humor about it
arguably should be the solo movie
because it's Han Solo and he's a funny
guy yeah if you're not gonna get that
cuz not once this do I feel charmed by
him in any of these trailers I mean I
think it's gonna be like a space cowboy
like movie like very traditional very in
in the genre go nicely with the Star
Wars brand that's kind of not what I
wanted I wanted the lego movie y'all saw
how well doing the last Jedi where you
did something completely different went
opinions are subjective you're still
wrong but I get it I get it I totally
get it yeah I could say what I want
right no no no you're allowed to have
your own opinion
thank you what's right or wrong when you
want just no I'm trying to subscribe
click that notification belt
hey cases that's her name on Instagram
and Twitter I follow her a couple of my
friends followed her my girlfriend
follows her you should follow her too
because she is constantly posting photos
of herself just the way Instagram is
designed for I don't know what else do
you use you I have my own channel
I'm working on it look for Casey's
private listed videos on her YouTube
channel put all the videos that I have
on the richest in Screen Rant
on my channel as a playlist so you can
see all that and you can see like my
comedy videos and singing videos yeah
she's a comedian so you catch her in
North Hollywood performing a karaoke bar
she's she's really good she'll be
[Laughter]
signing off officially now